voilà un acte d'achat normale en
normandie la charge chouchou massalé une
gamme de produits réunionnais font
partie des rayons leclerc comment cela
est-il possible
comment le modèle a été créé
[Musique]
tout part donc de se chouchouter sur les
remparts du cirque de salazie plus de
5000 tonnes sont produits chaque année
partie intégrante du patrimoine de la
réunion tout est bon dans le chouchou
[Musique]
oui
voilà pourquoi chez hot et grand mère on
le traite dans le respect de la
tradition pour poser
[Musique]
on a réceptionné le futsal asie donc
faire sa part en salle de barrage pour
qu avant midi en fait sa part en cuisson
conditionnement et pasteurisation
[Musique]
on mise vraiment sûr c'est justement sur
le côté très traditionnelle dans les
recettes c'est parce que je suis fou
massa allait déjà sa part lui-même
dans toutes les enseignes de la réunion
ces produits représentatifs sont
dispersés dans les rayons concurrents
une rencontre a fait germer une idée
la demande est né en 2009 les
producteurs locaux ont interpellé michel
edouard leclerc en disant monsieur
leclerc
est-ce que vous pouvez nous aider nous
entrepreneurs industriels producteurs
locaux à référencer les produits dans
les magasins métropolitain la réponse a
été oui simplement que en 2009 2010
lorsqu'on a initié ce chantier les
producteurs se voyaient entre eux comme
des concurrents potentiels et donc on a
fermé le dossier parce que les
mentalités n'étaient pas prêtes
je pense que nos six chez leclerc à la
réunion nous n'étions pas prêts et c'est
vrai qu'au cours de ces dix dernières
années on a pris conscience de cause de
ce que c'est que la dimension de la
mutualisation et la dimension en fin de
compte de travailler pour dans l'intérêt
général du plus grand nombre une
entreprise comme leclerc à la réunion
acteur deuxième acteur de la grande
distribution ne peut pas être insensible
au développement de son territoire
il a donc fallu attendre disons que le
collectif grandissent mûrissent le
projet et celle ananas qui a ouvert les
portes de l'export un jour on a décidé
de commencer de commencer par les anars
parce qu'il y avait de la demande
le commerce ça pas de taille on a tous
mes grands parents ils ont démarré comme
ça et c'est pas aujourd'hui par des
deuxième acteur qu'il faut être assis
dans un bureau forcément c'est au
contact du terrain
aujourd'hui le plein de bande passante
du coup tu fais moi de la qualité mais
moi le bon prix il faut que tu gagnes ta
vie pour qu'on gagne notre vie et il ya
vraiment un contrat gagnant gagnant et
c'est super intéressant pour des petites
entreprises comme la note parce que ça
me ça nous fait rêver ou si on commence
à pas grand chose un petit garage de
chez nous on passe à un atelier de 250
m² donc ça on passe vraiment dans un
autre une autre dimension et avoir le
cléac'h qui nous accompagnent qui nous
pousse ben je pense que c'est ce que je
souhaite à plein de petites entreprises
comme la mienne
[Applaudissements]
direction la normandie avec une centrale
d'achat qui ouvre les portes de la
métropole pour nos produits
john ont commencé à regrouper tous ses
partenaires de la réunion sous la
spéciation rhino des talents nous avons
créé une liste de produits avec l'équipe
des réunions des talents que nous
stockons en centrale et au fil de l'eau
les magasins comment de ses produits et
une re nous avons un acheteur en
centrale qui commandent ces produits
pour rire produit n'est pour éviter les
ruptures il est commande directement à
la réunion ça arrive par bateau s'est
déchargée au havre ensuite de plus le
havre ça arrive sur notre centrale à
lisieux en ce cas d'armande et de l'asca
normande ça arrive dans nos magasins
voilà donc comment nos produits se
retrouvent à chuter en normandie
le modèle existe peut-il s'étendre aux
500 enseignes leclerc de france peut-il
être répliqué à d'autres enseignes
c'est le souhait de la collectivité
départementale qui rassemble aujourd'hui
ses actes autour de la table
la réussite de cette ambition passe par
tout simplement un travail collectif
porté par plusieurs partenaires et nous
saluons l'engagement qui a été pris par
leclerc pour pouvoir justement nous
offrir cette belle opportunité
et c'est aussi quelque part la
concrétisation de notre présence au
salon international de l'agriculture
puisque maintenant les portes s'ouvrent
à la réunion et les produits agricoles
de la réunion les produits transformés
de la réunion vont pouvoir se retrouver
sur les étals de plusieurs grandes
surfaces
ici en métropole le lisseur métropole z1
compris hier c'est depuis ici
on à savoir faire et il faut le faire
savoir pour ça excellent la nasse
victorien qu'on va se faire bouffer
comme ça sont basses on continue à
chaque la bataille de gagner en
flexibilité et en os et en vitesse
d'approvisionnement parce que le coin
quelques soucis nicolas c'est justement
un problème comment être compétitifs par
rapport à nos concurrents va dire
mondiaux parce qu'aujourd'hui on observe
tout le monde est prêt et du faut
absolument qu'on arrive à vous apporter
ses solutions nous autres compagnies
aériennes
l'idée c'est vraiment de vous aider à
développer nos produits
les 47 jours bat aux points et confiance
41 à partir de mort et ses 30 jours par
son agresseur pour moi la collectivité
doit est né à l'avant sage mais à un
moment donné
la présence du département aujourd'hui
c'est bien surtout attaché à non
seulement nous permettre de fédérer
mieux on a aussi entendu parlé tout à
l'heure et ça fait un moment qu'on bosse
dessus c'est la logistique locale
vous avez entendu parmi la liste
métropolitaine qui est celle de leclerc
aujourd'hui que nous pmi qui nous permet
d'avoir de bénéficier des tarifs
on a aujourd'hui pas arrivé chez leclerc
mais il faut aussi organiser cette
logistique localement et là dessus je
pense que le débranchement un rôle à
jouer